The new HBO series inspired by the classic
comic book series Watchmen has been shrouded
in mystery thus far, with stories and characters
kept largely under wraps.
While we wait to learn the truth, here's a
look at everything we know and think we know.
Rumors about Lost co-creator Damon Lindelof
wanting to develop a Watchmen series brewed
as early as 2014, but it wasn't until August
2018 that Variety reported HBO had officially
given the show the greenlight.
In November 2017, at Vulture Festival L.A.,
Lindelof talked to The Good Place creator
Mike Schur about his motivations for developing
the series, saying,
"Watchmen it was dangerous…the reason that
I'm doing this is these are dangerous times,
and we need dangerous shows."
In May 2018, Lindelof posted a five-page letter
on Instagram addressed to Watchmen fans, retelling
pieces of his own life story in the non-linear
style in which we learn the story of Dr. Manhattan
in Watchmen #4.
He went on to describe his vision as not so
much an adaptation as a "remix" of the original
story likening the comic book series to the
Bible's Old Testament and his series to the
New Testament.
So far, the only major character from the
comics confirmed to appear in the series is
the mastermind Ozymandias, played by Jeremy
Irons, and he's clearly much older than he
was in the original story.
There's also the cult of Rorschach, but it's
doubtful the original is among them.
The other masked characters all appear brand
new.
The question still remains: If the events
of the HBO Watchmen series take place after
the events of the comic book series, then
did things unfold as they did in the comic
book series?
For example, did Ozymandias' plan conclude
with the appearance of the artificial alien
like in the comics, or with the faked Dr.
Manhattan assault on New York City from Zack
Snyder's film?
And what happened to the other characters
from the comic?
In May 2018, The Hollywood Reporter revealed
that Regina King, Louis Gossett Jr., Don Johnson,
Adelaide Clemens, Tim Blake Nelson, and Andrew
Howard had been cast in the series pilot,
and that King would be the lead.
There was no information about who the actors
would be playing...
"I can't say anything!"
"You really can't?"
"You might disappear if I do!"
...but since-released images, a leaked character
breakdown, the trailer, and the series' IMDb
page, has shed some light.
King's character is Angela Abraham, who will
be one of the series' masked vigilantes, it
seems.
She wears black leather clothing, including
a hooded jacket and a white shirt.
A greyish-black material covers the bottom
half of her face.
In the trailer, she also pins what appears
to be a police badge to her outfit.
Nelson is listed on IMDb with the name Looking
Glass, making it seem likely he's playing
the vigilante with the reflective mask.
Most of the others are listed with what appear
to be vigilante codenames: Clemens is Pirate
Jenny, Howard is Red Scare, and Gossett is
Old Man.
Johnson's as-yet-unnamed character is one
of the most prominently featured in the trailer,
and it seems likely he plays a high-ranking
police officer.
A leaked character breakdown mentions a woman
who is "wife of the police chief, Judd."
If the breakdown is to be believed, there's
a good chance Judd is Johnson's character.
In June 2018, Deadline reported Yahya Abdul-Mateen
II had been added to HBO's Watchmen cast,
and it won't be Mateen's first role in a superhero
production; he was the vengeful antagonist
Black Manta in Aquaman.
While not a lot is known about his role so
far, Abdul-Mateen's character Cal Abraham
appears to be the husband of Angela Abraham.
He's listed as her stay-at-home husband in
a leaked character breakdown, and a shot in
the first Watchmen teaser trailer shows the
two embracing.
"Are we safe?"
In January 2018, seasoned television director
Nicole Kassell was confirmed as director of
the Watchmen's pilot, as well as executive
producer for the series.
Kassell directed two episodes of Lindelof's
The Leftovers, and she's had steady directing
work since her first TV directorial credit
for an episode of the CBS medical drama 3
lbs.
Much of that work includes credits on successful,
acclaimed shows such as The Closer, Castle
Rock, Better Call Saul, The Killing, Westworld,
and The Americans, among others.
HBO's official Watchmen Instagram account
has been a wealth of cryptic but interesting
reveals.
Many images are little more than production
photos, but there are some more intriguing
images, including short videos referencing
the original Watchmen or simply showing us
a slice of this alternate America.
One video shows an altered U.S. flag flapping
in the breeze, while another shows the skull-and-bones
pirate flag we briefly see in the trailer
that reminds any Watchmen reader of the "Tales
of the Black Freighter" pirate story.
Yet another video shows what appears to be
Regina King's vigilante character walking
toward a police officer and one briefly shows
her unmasked, looking distressed.
One more clip begins with two armed police
officers and cuts to Jeremy Irons as Ozymandias...
"It's only just begun."
...while another shows the aging superhero
blowing out a single candle on a birthday
cake.
In the Watchmen comic, Rorschach is a mentally
unstable vigilante who believes in taking
extreme measures for the greater good.
He's killed by Dr. Manhattan, but we soon
learn he's arranged for his journal to be
mailed to a right-wing publication, the New
Frontiersman, in the hopes that Ozymandias'
plot would be revealed.
The story's final page takes place in the
Frontiersman office, where an exhausted editor
tells his assistant to pick a piece of reader
mail from an overflowing pile, where Rorschach's
journal sits, and to run a story based on
it.
"Um, well, I guess something from the crank
file."
What seems to be a fanatical group based on
Rorschach exists in the future-set series,
strongly implying the vigilante's journal
and its revelations did see the light of day.
Yet the New Frontiersman is portrayed as a
small fringe publication, so there's no guarantee
any story it ran would be received as anything
more than a conspiracy theory by society at
large.
This new pack of Rorschachs may very well
be culled from Frontiersman readers and like-minded
conspiracy theorists.
Another Watchmen cast member came to light
in January 2019 when it was announced Good
Trouble's Dustin Ingram would join the show.
Bleeding Cool spotted a brief reveal about
Ingram's Watchmen character buried in a story
about Ingram being cast in Amazon's upcoming
Utopia: Deadline offhandedly pointed out that
in Watchmen, Ingram will play, quote, "Agent
Petey, a junior FBI agent, with a vast knowledge
of the vigilantes (the Watchmen)."
Is Petey an expert on the new vigilantes like
Looking Glass and Regina Park's masked character,
or does his expertise revolve around Rorschach,
Nite Owl and the other comic characters?
Deadline's parenthetical mention of "the Watchmen"
doesn't help much, because in the comic book
series, "Watchmen" is not a team name.
None of the heroes refer to themselves as
Watchmen.
The title comes from the work of the Roman
poet Juvenal, whose most famous line can be
translated from Latin, "Who watches the watchmen?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.